sie rennen hin zur schule in purer
verzweiflung nur einen gedanken den kopf
was ist mit meinem kind denn in der
schule erschießt ein irrer ihre kinder
massaker amoklauf an einer grundschule
in der 17.000 einwohner stadt juli in
texas der killer verbarrikadierte sich
in der schule seine opfer unschuldige
kinder hatten keine chance er tötet 19
kinder und zwei erwachsene darunter i
war mir alles lehrerin in der vierten
klasse
ist der kindermörder der fast selbst
noch ein kind ist er heißt salvador
ramos ging auf die highschool in jubel
die kurz nach seinem 18 geburtstag so
sagte er sich ganz legal handfeuerwaffen
hier sehen wir ihn rein gehen in die
schule und offenbar auch ein gewehr auf
seinem instagram account posierte er mit
waffen kurz vor der tat schrieb er dort
kryptische nachrichten und ein mädchen
die die tat angekündigt haben könnten
warum ist es tote erschossen im gefecht
mit der polizei und hier sehen wir ihn
hier betritt er bewaffnet die schule ist
das bisher einzige video von der tat
laut ermittlern skiservice zuvor seine
großmutter in ihrer wohnung sie im
krankenhaus untergebracht dann vor zur
schule auf dem weg eine unfall ging dann
mit einer schutzweste im rucksack und
ein gewehr in der hand zu fuß weiter die
sicherheitsleute in der schule
versuchten noch ihn aufzuhalten
vergeblich er konnte sich drinnen
verbarrikadieren und wild um sich
schießen
ja noch immer warten verzweifelte eltern
vor der schule können ihr kind in die
arme schließen oder bekommen sie doch
eine todesnachricht hier schildern sie
uns die unerträgliche ungewissheit
und auch us präsident biden hat sich
geäußert er weiß ganz genau wie es ist
ein kind zu verlieren er sagte das ist
es würde jemanden einem ein stück seele
wegnehmen eine ganze nation ist gelähmt
vor schmerz die flagge vor dem weißen
haus auf halbmast
ich hatte gehofft als sie präsident
wurde dass sich das nicht noch einmal
tun müsste ein weiter das massaker in uk
texas in der grundschule junge
unschuldige zweit dritt und
viertklässler die vielen kleinen kinder
die mit erlebt haben was passiert ist
die ihre freunde sterben sahen als wären
sie auf einem schlachtfeld um himmels
willen das wird sie für den rest ihres
lebens verfolgen die eltern die ihre
kinder nie wieder sehen werden sie
werden nie mit ihnen ins bett bringen
können und kuscheln können die eltern
werden nie wieder dieselben sein ein
kind zu verlieren
es ist als würde ihnen ein stück ihrer
seele weggerissen werden da ist
unglaubliche lehre in deiner brust es
fühlt sich so an als würde man hinein
gesorgt werden als ob man da nie wieder
herauskommen kann ersticken es wird nie
mehr so wie vorher heute abend bitte ich
die nation für sie zu beten gibt den
eltern und geschwistern die kraft in der
dunkelheit
als nation müssen wir uns fragen wann in
gottes namen wir der waffenlobby die
stirn bieten werden wir tun das wovon
wir wissen dass es getan werden muss ich
habe es satt wir müssen handeln und
sagen sie mir nicht dass wir keinen
einfluss auf dieses gemetzel haben
können wir müssen den mut haben der
industrie die stirn zu bieten unser
gebet heute abend es waren diese eltern
die im bett liegen und sich fragen werde
ich wieder schlafen können was sage ich
zu meinen anderen kindern was ist mit
morgen
[Musik]
betroffen der us präsident der sich zum
ziel gesetzt hat die waffengesetze in
den usa zu ändern dort keine einfache
sache das geht nicht ohne den senate
sind dem präsidenten auch die hände
gebunden
trotzdem dieses starke appell des
präsidenten und die situation vor ort
ist weiterhin unübersichtlich die eltern
warten in einem gemeindehaus auf
nachricht auf die nachricht ob sie ihre
kinder in die arme schließen können oder
ob sie vielleicht doch eine
todesnachricht bekommen
ein vater schildert uns seine
unerträgliche ungewissheit
ich frage immer wieder nach was los ist
aber niemand sagt mir etwas niemand sagt
mir irgendwas nur einer der eltern sagte
dass möglicherweise kinder im
beerdigungsinstitut
festgehalten werden das hat mich hierher
gebracht um heraus was los
es gibt kinder die sind noch da wo meine
tochter ist noch nicht
und sie konnten sich nicht bei ihm
melden sie wissen nicht wo sie ist
nein wie geht es ihnen
ich bin nur verwirrt und besorgt man
versuche herauszufinden wo meine kleine
ist
aber niemand hat ihnen gesagt dass es
ihr gut geht oder dass sie verletzt ist
es gibt viele verwirrte eltern die nicht
wissen wo vollgas hier ist das versuche
ich herauszufinden
und wer ist frau dass ihr das programm
ist eine lehrerin
unvorstellbar dieser dieses
unerträgliche warten der eltern schauen
wir auf diese kleine stadt in texas
17.000 einwohner in dieser stadt wird
nichts wieder so sein wie vorher auch
der sheriff der stadt sichtlich
erschüttert über das was dort passiert
dies war heute ein tragisches und
sinnloses ereignis welches mir das herz
gebrochen hat unsere gedanken und gebete
sind bei all unseren familien während
wir diesen tag und die kommenden tage
durchstehen mein herz wurde heute
gebrochen wir sind eine kleine
gemeinschaft und wir brauchen ihre
gebete damit wir das durchstehen können
19 tote kinder zwei erwachsene unfassbar
amokläufer auch an schulen sie passieren
in den usa in trauriger regelmäßigkeit
erst vor gut einer woche hatte ein
schütze mit einem sturmgewehr in buffalo
im us bundesstaat new york in einem
supermarkt das feuer eröffnet zehn
menschen erschossen und drei weitere
verletzt und auch in deutschland konnte
in essen einen amoklauf offenbar gerade
noch so verhindert werden
19 tote kinder erneut ein massaker in
den usa ein amoklauf an einer
grundschule leider keine seltenheit
immer wieder erreichen uns die
nachrichten solcher grausamen taten vor
nicht einmal zwei wochen amoklauf in
einem supermarkt in buffalo im
bundesstaat new york der rassistische
killer hat es auch schwarze abgesehen
erschießt zehn menschen hauptsächlich
afroamerikaner doch nicht nur in den usa
häufen sich die amokläufe auch bei uns
kommt es immer wieder zu schrecklichen
bluttaten vor zwei wochen kann nur knapp
eine katastrophe verhindert werden in
essen stoppt die polizei den 16-jährigen
jeremy noch bevor er seine amok pläne an
einem gymnasium verwirklichen kann er
war kurz davor sich eine
maschinenpistole zu besorgen hatte
material für rohrbomben und eine
gefährliche nagel bombe sowie weitere
waffen das ausmaß des massakers damit
kaum auszudenken zuletzt vor fünf tagen
kann ein attentäter in bremerhaven
gestoppt werden auch sein ziel eine
schule eine mutige sekretärin stellt
sich ihm in den weg wird
lebensgefährlich verletzt aber
verhindert vermutlich ein horrorszenario
denn der amokläufer war schwer bewaffnet
mit einer armbrust und messern ein
passant handelt geistesgegenwärtig kick
die waffe des attentäters zur seite
neben den quälenden fragen der motiven
der täter bleibt vor allem die wie
solche massaker verhindert werden können